[MUSIC PLAYING]
SHENAZ ZACK: A very,
very warm welcome
to all you amazing ladies.
On behalf of Google, I am
really excited to be here
to celebrate all you strong,
passionate, and persevering
women, along with
Women Techmakers,
and their global vision
of providing visibility,
community, and resources.
And I truly appreciate you
spending your Saturday with us
away from your family.
I know it's not easy,
definitely for me, sneaking out
of the house on a Saturday.
So thank you.
This is our fourth year of
hosting our global event series
in celebration of International
Women's Day, where
we celebrate women's
achievements and campaign
for gender equality.
This year's theme for
International Women's Day
is Telling our Story.
So I'm going to lead by
example and tell my story.
My story has a couple of
interesting sharp turns.
So let's go through that.
I grew up on a small village
called Gholvad in India,
on an orchard.
It's around three and a
half hours from Mumbai,
on the western seaboard.
My first exposure
to computers was
when I was in my sixth
grade, when my family bought
a PC, first PC for our house,
for their trucking business.
And I spent hours
tinkering on it.
Little did I know
that I would end up
in Silicon Valley working
for one of the leading tech
companies in the world.
Our village and our neighboring
town had only one college.
So at the age of 15,
I moved to Bombay
to continue my education.
And actually, that's where
I first realized and learned
about gender bias, as I was the
only girl in my class for two
years studying electronics.
I finished my graduation,
went on to do my MBA.
I joined BMG in India
and had to launch albums
from international artists
like Whitney Houston, Prince,
in the Indian market.
Fast forward a few years.
Myself and my dog--
yes, you heard me right,
my dog, literal dog-- moved
to beautiful California,
and where I became a
prisoner of paradise.
And I called myself that
because I was on an H- visa.
I was in this land of
opportunity with tons to do,
but I couldn't work because
I was on an H-4 visa.
I wasn't going to
let that stop me,
so I decided to pursue
my passion of filmmaking.
And I joined community
college, and I
started interning at local
organizations like Channel 4
KRON and KKUP 91.5 FM, which
is the only listener-supported
radio station in the
entire United States.
I started working with
them and later on joined
their board of directors.
But again, I was the
only woman of color.
Then, I followed my heart and
joined an Oscar-nominated, Emmy
award-winning production
house in the Bay Area
called Concentric Media,
where I edited and co-produced
a documentary about
AIDS in Ethiopia.
And at that time, I
realized that technology
had a lot to offer
in this industry,
in the filmmaking industry.
And there's a lot
that could be done.
So I started knocking on
Google's door, especially
Google Video.
I got a job as a temp worker,
reviewing approximately 7,000
videos a day.
That part of my brain?
Locked away and thrown.
I don't want to ever go there.
But I had a break in my career.
I didn't have a US degree.
I had to start
somewhere, and I was
willing to start at
the bottom of the pole.
But thanks to amazing
and supportive colleagues
at Google, I became
a full time Googler,
and I transitioned to
product management,
which is what I wanted to do.
And I am proud to say that I
have been at Google for over 10
years now.
So today, as I stand
in front of you,
I'm humbled and
honored to introduce
an amazing line of
speakers and workshops,
and so I urge you all
to share your stories,
to inspire other young women.
At Google, difference
is our value.
And you can see
that from my story.
A diversity of
perspectives and ideas,
whether by gender, race, sexual
orientation, neurodiversity,
or a combination of them, lead
to a much better workplace,
to better decisions,
much more creative ideas,
and most important,
building better products,
because our products are used by
people from all walks of life.
So we at Google want to help
the entire tech industry become
more inclusive and accepting
by inspiring young students
to join computer science.
We want to create
an industry where
people can pursue their dreams,
build impactful technology,
and become leaders.
So I mentioned Women
Techmakers a couple of times.
And if you're wondering,
what is Women Techmakers,
it's Google's global program
for women in technology.
It was kicked off in 2012 by
then-VP Google[x], Megan Smith,
and is now led by
Natalie Villalobos,
who is our amazing
leader right now,
and a global team of Googlers.
Yay!
Off to Natalie.
[APPLAUSE]
And an amazing team
of Googlers who
are passionate about
empowering women
in technology to increase
visibility, community,
and resources.
60,000 women, in person, are
influenced by Women Techmakers,
as they not only host
this event but also host
Google I/O and Grace Hopper.
It also has a membership
program to offer
you curated resources and
community based on your career
level.
They also have a
Scholars Program
which supports women
to obtain CS degrees.
And there is an
incredible amount of work
that goes in from 320
volunteers who around the world
are developing diverse
and inclusive ecosystems.
You can always learn more
about Women Techmakers
at womentechmakers.com.
Telling our story.
This is the team
we are celebrating.
And I already told you my story.
I hope it inspired
some of you, or I
hope it inspires some kids.
But this is selected
as a rallying cry
to have each of us
become more visible,
which is definitely needed
at this point of time.
We need to still tell our
story to become more visible
and ensure our unique
contributions to this industry
are being known.
So please, all of you
share your story today
and listen to other stories.
And also, amplify that by
sharing it on social media with
the hashtag #wtm17.
Diversity in technology.
When you hear that
term, sometimes you
only think United States, but
as you look at this global map,
women around the world
are coming together
to increase the visibility,
community, and resources
to enable more women
to join the industry.
And that's why across
March and April,
Women Techmakers will be
hosting 15 global summits,
over 140 community meetups.
And we believe in
supporting communities
wherever they are,
so on April 7,
we will be hosting a summit
in Sydney, Australia.
And today, three summits
are taking place.
One in Seattle, New
York's already kicked off,
and we are off.
And so we encourage and
empower women to see--
it's so good to see all of you
over there in the audience.
And again, please share your
stories and hashtag them
#wcm17.
[MUSIC PLAYING]